In the last video we had Pete starting an open-ended mutual fund
that was managed by Pete Inc.
Mutual Funds normally have nice grand names
maybe they called this the Saturn Fund
and if there is a Saturn Fund out there, I just picked that name at random
I'm not implying that this is you or anything like that
I just made up that name on the fly
But it's managed by Pete Inc. and we called it an open-ended fund
because at any time one of the people who owned a share
or unit in the fund can redeem it back from the fund
that Pete or the management company would say
If you want your $180 back we'll buy that
we'll give you $180, you give back the share, and then we cancel the share
and if anyone wants to add to the fund
if they want to invest
the corporation can create new shares
and then issue it to people - sell it to people
and their money would go into the common pool
and the management company would take fees off of it
But that probably had you asking
If this is an open-ended fund, what is a closed-ended fund
or do they even exist?
And they do
That's what I'm going to talk about here
Closed-end funds
and closed-end funds on some level are a little bit simpler
What happens in a closed-end fund is that
all of the investors are essentially
Or I guess you can say that the share structure
is locked from the beginning
So if Pete wanted to start a closed-end mutual fund
he would once again register a corporation with the SEC
he would market it it
he would tell everyone "Hey I'm Pete, I'm an awesome investor"
"Here's my track record"
and then he would just get a bunch of investors
so lets say he's able to find 20 investors
and that's all he's able to find
so this is 20 right here, and I'm not going to count
but, let's say that there's 20 slices right over here
He gets 20 people, so let's say they each give $100
so he is able to raise $2000. 20 times $100
So he is able to raise $2000
And once that happens, the fund is closed.
Pete's going to do his best to manage this
So Pete will manage this and he will still take a management fee
Maybe the same 1%
But what's fundamentally different here
and he can market - well he doesn't have to market the fund anymore
because he can no longer get new investors
and this is actually the main difference
An open-ended mutual fund
at any point in time
or I should say at the end of trading
at the end of a day, they can lose investors, or they can gain investors
so it's an incentive for an open-ended fund
to constantly market itself
because the manager wants to manage more money
so that he gets more of a management fee
And a closed-end fund
They'll market it right when they are creating the fund
But once they create it
So lets say he just got his 20 investors
Then it is closed
He can't create any more shares
or cancel any more shares
But what can happen
so you might say
well in a closed-end fund
How do these people let's say you're holding
one of these shares
let's say that you're holding one share
right over here
what happens if you want to
If you need to buy a house, or if you owe money to somebody
so you want to get the value of your share back
and the answer with a closed-end fund
is that you would then go sell your share to someone else
so this right here you can trade it
You can trade it
and you would trade it just you would
trade the stock of any company
And in fact when you go and buy or sell
a stock of IBM, most of the time
you're just buying or selling it from someone else
You're not transacting with IBM
the company
You're trading in the secondary market
you're not dealing with the actual corporation
so that's where the investor
get's their liquidity
and when we say liquidity
it allows them to convert it into cash
because they can trade it
So the big difference
open-ended fund: when an investor wants their money back
they have to deal with the fund itself
the fund will buy back their share
If some wants to invest in a fund
the fund will sell them the share
so they're always dealing with the fund itself
in a closed-end fund
once the fund is created it's share pool is fixed
and if someone wants to buy or sell a share
it happens in the secondary market
so they're buying and selling from each other
they're not dealing with the actual fund manager
The disadvantage from the fund manager here
is it's much less flexible
in terms of growing or shrinking the fund
The advantage is this fund manager
doesn't have to keep cash around
in case the share holders want to redeem
In the open-ended fund we saw that the manager
has to keep some cash around in case one of these
investors wants their money back
here - the closed-end fund - he knows that no one
can get their money back right here
so he or she can invest as they see fit